this one's my favorite so i i'm
probably going to make a lot of people
blush right now because most people
get red in the face because we're all
guilty of this check out
is easily the most vapid lazy call to
action on the face of the planet you
should all 86 it from your vocab
immediately and think instead about what
active verbs
really define the call to action you're
intending right so
check out is is meant to be like go and
see or go and look or learn more which
are all
you know not the most ideal verbs either
because they're kind of general but what
you want to do is think about
what's the value behind what you want
someone to do and try to pull that value
out front so they can get an
understanding if they were to click
to check out my link right there to
click it where what's going to happen so
i'll show you some examples
of how to use better call to actions
here so this is my linkedin feed where i
do a lot of my social
and i'll walk through each of the parts
of this so the call to action here
is it's not even really a verb
i'm just saying more real talk for
entrepreneurs and underdogs with my rad
paul's jim and chris
so i'm sort of even avoiding
a direct call to action and making it
more
a little bit tricky here like i like
this technique a lot because i feel like
it's subtle
it's not selling but it's selling right
a couple other things that i do that
i'll break down
um in the slides as well but just to go
over them why we're here
so is it it's a tactic right i'm i'm
trying to make you feel like you know me
already
i'm bringing you into my orb for trust
we're talking about the book
the secret i'm using the word barf which
is fun to say i love onomatopoeia
um people hear what what they read so
they're they're hearing that
and they're laughing i know they are
because they've all responded to me and
then i'm giving some advice this is that
authority piece we talked about before
so the secret isn't a secret at all i'm
not saying
i don't think it is or maybe it is i'm
i'm making as though like
i know it and then it's a mindset so i'm
being very clear about
what what i believe is true and really
commanding you into
believing me so the other one i wanted
to touch on was another way to
use that call to action without saying
check out so in this case
um again i'm i'm using that subtle thing
more on why the hard ways work with my
pal mark evans
we talked about what's the value behind
clicking something
so right here i'm saying why the hard
ways work so what are the hard ways
that's what i want you to ask yourself
and i'll read this out so you can you
can hear it in the beginning we didn't
think so much that we were building a
company but that we were building a
community
so all of that is also meant to be
controversial right because
you know why why wouldn't i think i was
building a community which
that's what everybody thinks you're a
company when you're when you're a
startup
right it should be focused on building
this company and having this vision
and what i'm saying we're all that our
vision was more
of like a culture a hangout place right
and it turns out that this was smart af
so i'm using my
vernacular how i talk here smart and
then af because i
like to be a little bit um rogue
right and then i love using the
parentheses as well because this is a
statement under the breath
if i don't say so myself with a little
rock hand so
visually you have the parentheses you've
got the ellipses
and then you've got my um arrows here
that are all
pushing you like a very visual call to
action to click this
and um find out you know what are these
hard ways